today the secret state announced
designation of the as a specially des
global terror february
[موسيقى]
اعادت تصنيفهم منظمه مجموعه ارهابيه خاصه
وليس منظمه ارهابيه يعني في تلاعب بالكلام
ان العصا والجزره اذا توقفت عن القصف
يعني لم تعودوا تشكلوا خطر لتهديد الملاحه
العالميه فسن فع عنكم هذا التصنيف
المؤقت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في مطلق الاحوال هذا التصنيف لن يضيف شيئا
ولن يقلل شيئا وحول في البدايه من خلال
هذه الضربه ان يوجه رساله ويقول يجب ان
تتوقفوا لم يتوقفوا قال انه انه صادر
اسلحه اتيه من ايران ووجه نداءات لايران
وبعث برسائل لايران ولم
[موسيقى]
يتوقفوا نفذت القوات البحريه في القوا
المسلحه اليمنيه عمليه استهداف لسفينه
جينكو بيكاردي الامريكيه في خليج عدن بعدد
من الصواريخ البحريه المناسبه وكانت
الاصابه دقيقه ومباشره بفضل
الله